what makes comic-con such a such an
ideal place for you to be telling the
world about your projects about cut cut
roll City a new film I got coming out
scheduled for February 2019 the
comic-con first of all it's a place that
I love to come to as a fan and I've
worked my first film here the man with
the iron fists had a great reception I
came with half of some of our great
reception and I think the people here
get me you know people that come out to
comic-con I think they get the RZA they
get the wu-tang they get the vibe and I
thought Carter City be another great
product to bring to them there's you
know I can't I don't do no spoilers in
my film but in love of comics my lead
character name is blink play bashed I'll
make more
he's a graphic novelist man yeah I mean
and his goal is to get his comic you
know pressed and presented to the world
and him with the college forward and
he's you know he's a geek and all yeah
but he's forced to take another world
yeah now we talked to me more earlier
today okay in a press lion and he's got
all this energy he's super enthusiastic
about about what he's doing and really
your whole cast for cutthroat City is
phenomenal how did they all come
together like whose cash first um when
it when it came to this particular
version of the script shall make we
can't became I blink
you know Terrance was always the same so
Thomas may have been you know early from
Evie because we went to three renditions
to the scripts Harris was on first but
shy meek was like I watched him and dope
right wasn't sure this love the movie
love this comedic timing but when I
watch the get down which you know I
gotta watch to get down know this kid
this kid now I'm gonna telling my wife
like this kid got sound special you know
and uh and my twelve-year-old son who's
11 at the time is a big fan of him from
this other TV thing he did call the some
kind of Club
that on Adult Swim he had some some
comedy thing okay you know my son was
into them and I was like he showed me
some old videos I said wow this kid
actually has the talent to be whatever
he is put in front of them
yeah and then we met yeah and when we
met I saw it I said you know what this
is my blink right here yeah and he uh he
read this group he said he would love to
be that character and bonbons and we are
as a kind of sort of action movies and
martial arts movies it must've been wild
having blade having Wesley what was that
like I'm a big fan of Wesley and it was
a honor found to come and uh trust me
with his talent yeah Wesley is a
treasure you know we all got a somewhat
like I said we got tip I asked him you
think about the great Marvel Renaissance
is happening in movies that's actually
feeding our industry and you think about
blade being a pioneer of that yeah and
and here it is mister blade himself yeah
is being directed by DeRosa you know and
we're both martial artists and we have a
seafood that we share okay yeah and but
for him to trust me with that camera in
front of him it was a great tribute to
me and a great respect and honor and I'm
so you know happy that he came to join
that party is that how you got him
involved in the project that you guys
share a massive share Saifu yeah but he
read it as well yeah and uh it was some
a few things in the character he wanted
to bring mm-hmm and he was like if I
could bring this particular energy who
he call him he calls me bong
bong-bong-bong you know I could come on
dance with you and I was like
yeah actually that energy is what what
was missing it was something that was
missing in a character that wasn't so
stereotype that he saw and he helped
elevate elevate that a character force
so what can we expect from this movie
what's the tone gonna be like I don't
know went back to the Ninth Ward in New
Orleans putting this movie together what
can we expect this film is is like I
said this is for men with aspirations
but because of environment because of
the aftermath of Hurricane Katrina
desperation turns to desperation right
and when a man is desperate he's gonna
make some bad decisions and then one bad
decision this keeps chain react and it's
a meowt yes all the bad decisions and
and you may even start liking what
you're doing you know mmm
I think there's a character Demetrius
ship who does a great job in this film I
want to say he doesn't great job you
know I was I was always you know like
anybody would be you you know you watch
when you see some characters play you
know iconic character he played Tupac
you know you wonder where the hoardings
be able to watch him and not think of
Tupac Manny you can you duck you do yeah
he said it all that put it behind him
and he became miracle yeah and I think
that when people see him now they're
gonna be calling a miracle but um you
know to see the you know to see these
kids you know going to do their changes
and trying to find themselves and
starting and I think miracle he kind of
was starting to enjoy a little bit of
what this other life was waiting so for
fans who's gonna watch this movie
cutthroat City be prepared for a great
story first and foremost we got some
cool action and I think there's a
undertone story that could resonate with
all of us which is what do we do
we have no choice there are a lot of
movies where the setting is not just a
setting but they people talk about this
thing like it's a character right and
New Orleans specifically has a lot of
character but the backstory is amazing
and also tragic do you think this is the
part of this is make sure people don't
forget definitely you can't forget you
won't forget you shuffle again you know
when I thought about you know when I was
reading the script and you know before
we you know went to different drafts the
one thing that we made was that Katrina
is a physical mental emotional social
and political disaster mm-hmm there's a
great line in the film I like the I like
people to watch movies instead of talk
about a month but there's a great line
where you know they de Meyer will play
by Kat Graham she's telling blink like
we're not gonna play the blame game yeah
because he's like you know things that
ain't bad and he's like it's this team
was full and she's like a name team was
full you were educated black man mm-hmm
he's like blank playing game you crazy
like me more the president the
government the city the mayor yeah they
they all be building around us but
nobody in doing for the knife water
hmm we still on the water yeah we still
but and and and and even after that
story took place in our film which is
basically I feel don't take place 2005
maybe it's gonna take you all the way to
the middle of 2005 top of 2006 the
people in the Ninth Ward was still
suffering up to seven eight years later
yeah and even if you go there now you
could see Wow Katrina was here yeah it's
like it's like on somebody go to the
feeding on your wall that you can't wash
it off yeah it was hit and uh I'm point
on one other thing that that out I was
excited about and the dialogue was uh
you know in the in the you know in the
black community you know we have our
ideas of you know we hear the rumors of
what happened some people say dad just
was Hurricane Katrina some people say
that the the levee was exploded
yeah and you know that that dialogue is
touched upon as well in the film happy
yeah yeah so we touch upon that just to
just just to put the thought in the air
like we don't you know who knows what
happened for that particular
neighborhood we know what it was a heavy
King we know there was a flood but what
happened when those levees broke and why
those navies break yeah